[Music]
welcome back
so we're talking about the fourier
series and how we can approximate
functions
f of x periodic functions with
a infinite sum of sines and cosines of
increasingly high frequencies
okay so this is the basis of the uh fast
fourier transform
and lots of modern techniques um in in
compression and numerical solutions of
differential equations
and in the last few lectures i've shown
you how to do this with cosines and
sines
now i'm going to show you how to do this
with complex valued functions so f of x
doesn't have to be real
this could be a complex valued function
as well and in that case what we're
going to do is we're going to write this
as a sum an infinite sum
from k equals minus infinity to infinity
so this is a little bit different than
before
of some complex coefficient c
e to the i k x and you'll notice that i
went back to two pi periodic functions
to find from negative pi to pi because
my notation will be a little bit easier
here
and i want you to recall
kind of the euler's expansion of this
e to the i k x
is just cosine k x
plus i sine kx
okay and this is pretty easy to see if
you just take the taylor series
expansion of e to the
uh e to the x and you plug in i k x
then if you collect all of the real
terms you'll recover the
cosine series and if you recover all of
the terms that have an i
on the coefficient you'll recover the
sine taylor expansion
okay so this is what we're going to do
we're going to talk about
now the fourier series in terms of
complex
a complex basis e to the i k x where k
can go from negative infinity to
infinity integers
from minus infinity to infinity if you
wanted to you could of course expand
this out you could say that
my sum goes from k equals minus infinity
to infinity um
you could say that my my coefficients ck
are just some
alpha k plus i beta
k okay no big deal and then i could plug
in my
my euler's formula here for e to the i k
x is just cosine kx
plus i sine kx
okay and if you wanted to you could
expand this out you could collect all of
the real parts and all of the imaginary
parts
and you'd have some representation for
the real and the imaginary parts of your
function
f and if you were dealing with real
valued function f
at real valued functions f you could
derive
that there are some constraints on these
coefficients
in fact i'll just write it out so i'll
write out
in parentheses here that
c k equals
the complex conjugate of c minus k
if f of x is real
okay and you can derive that out
yourself you can expand this out and
basically try to kill all the imaginary
terms
and you'll arrive at this this
relationship here it's pretty simple
okay so that's that's a nice uh
expression this is kind of a nice
a more compact representation of the
fourier series than we had before before
we were writing it as sines and cosines
uh this is both more compact and it
expresses
uh complex functions as well as real
functions so it's more general also
but now what i want to do is i want to
convince you that these functions e to
the ikx
define an orthogonal basis
uh for my function space for my space of
all functions i want to i want to show
you that these
functions for different integer k's are
orthogonal to each other and form an
infinite dimensional vector space a
basis for this vector space
okay and that's something i didn't do
before i'm going to do now
we're going to to derive this okay
so the way i'm going to do that is i'm
going to define uh let's actually just
do it right here let's say that this is
defined to be some function
psi k i'm going to define my function
psi k to equal e to the i k x okay
and i'm going to say that this set of
all psi ks
is a basis so each of these psi's
is kind of a direction in function space
that's orthogonal to every other
psi k okay and then we're going to do
that is by we're actually going to
compute
the inner product of psi j with psi k
psi j psi k and we're going to show that
this inner product is
0 unless j equals k that's what it means
for these vectors to be orthogonal these
functions
to be orthogonal okay so
writing this out i'm just going to use
this uh inner product in hilbert space
from above so this is the integral
from negative pi to pi
of psi j times the complex conjugate of
psi k so psi j is just e to the
i j x
i is square root of negative one j is an
index an integer
times the complex conjugate of e to the
i
k x and complex conjugate of e to the i
something is e to the minus i that thing
dx good okay so that's not too bad this
is just the inner product that we've
defined earlier
of my basis function j with basis
function
k is my integral e to the i j x
e to the i minus i k x and now what i
can do is i can put
all of those exponents under the same
the same exponent i can multiply these
and add the exponents
and so that's going to equal again
integral minus
pi to pi e to the i
j minus k x
dx good nothing fancy going on here and
we actually know
how to integrate this this is not a hard
function to integrate e to the
anything x if i integrate it is um
one over that coefficient times the
function itself okay so this is actually
pretty easy for me to
to write out maybe i'll do this in blue
okay so this is
uh 1 over i
times j minus k times
e to the i j minus k
x and remember this is a definite
integral so we're actually evaluating
this from minus pi to pi
so we're evaluating this from minus pi
to pi okay and this is where i think it
gets kind of interesting
is that this function j minus k is just
this is just an integer okay this is e
to the i integer
x and so if i plug in pi
and minus pi for any of those integers
let's let's just say j minus k is is 2
okay so j minus k is 2. e to the i 2
x if i evaluate it at pi or minus pi i
get the same thing
because this function is 2 pi periodic e
to the
e to the i 2 pi is equal to e to the
minus i
2 pi they're the same function they both
equal
equal each other okay so this equals
0
if j does not equal to k so if j does
not equal k
then this is a positive or negative
integer this is just an integer e to the
i
integer x and if i plug in pi or minus
pi
those will be equal to each other that e
to the
you know i integer pi and e to the minus
i integer pi will be equal
and when i subtract them they cancel out
okay so i get
zero these really are orthogonal if j
does not equal
k but if j does equal k
so let's say j equals k then i get it's
a little bit funny because then this
becomes 0
and i'm dividing by 0. but you can use
any number of
mathematical formulas you can use
l'hopital's rule
to kind of take the limit and and remove
those you can think about
expanding this in the taylor series and
dividing the j minus k out
and what you get out is just an x term
evaluated at pi minus x evaluated at
minus pi
and what's pi minus minus pi
we get 2 pi if and only if
j equals k okay so i'll let you work
through the details of this yourself
that if j equals k then you can in fact
evaluate this
and what you get is just x evaluated at
pi
and minus pi and they add up to two pi
okay
good so what that shows is that these
functions
psi j and psi k are in fact orthogonal
to each other
so if j is not equal to k the inner
product is zero
if j is equal to k then they have a
non-trivial inner product of
2 pi in fact that's the the norm
squared of psi j with itself is 2 pi
that's how you you compute that and so
what that means is that these functions
these
psi k e to the i k x functions provide
an orthogonal
basis for my function space for my
hilbert space
functions okay and remember this is a
lot like
what we are used to in um in
in regular vector space if i have like
an x
and a y vector direction we've done this
before
and i have uh some
vector f then the way i compute this
vector
f is to take the inner product of f so
i'm just going to say vector f
equals inner product of f with
x in the x direction okay
plus inner product of f with y in the y
direction okay really simple this is
you've done this forever i'm assuming x
and y
are unit norm vectors so i don't have to
divide by the norm or anything like that
and so going back to our formula here
that's exactly what we have here these
coefficients
c k are just the inner product of f
with psi k okay so i'm going to write
this
as an infinite sum k equals minus
infinity
to infinity of
my there really should be a 1 over 2 pi
here
so let me just make this 1 over 2 pi
this whole thing equals 1 over 2 pi sum
from minus
uh infinity to infinity
of the inner product of f of x with
psi k in the psi
k direction okay and this is my
c k and this is my e to the i
k x function okay so this
infinite sum this complex valued fourier
series can be written
as a projection as a sum of f projected
onto each of these orthogonal basis
directions that's the component how much
of f is in that psi k direction
times that psi k vector and i'm dividing
by 1 over 2 pi
because i have to normalize for for the
norm of that
that vector okay so i think that's a
really really cool and geometrically
intuitive way of thinking about the
fourier series
is that my cosines and sines or if i
want to think in complex space my e to
the ik x's
form an orthogonal basis in which i can
represent
all functions okay so it's just like a
vector space like a regular vector space
we're used to
except there are infinitely many
directions it's not just x and y
there's psi 1 psi 2 all the way up to
psi infinity and all the way down to psi
negative infinity there's an
infinite set of these functions an
infinite basis
in which i can represent it's an
orthogonal basis in which i can
represent any function f of x
okay so we're going to use this to
approximate functions
we're going to think about what could go
wrong when we're approximating functions
maybe with discontinuities
and then we're going to derive the
fourier transform integral all right
thank you